all right Craig you're up buddy you sure
you have the system I've hacked into the
Pentagon the Chinese currency exchange
and Obama's Skype account I think I'll
be fine fine enough talk get to work
this guy's good huh he's the worst
why it's just he's not even typing yes
is it shouldn't he be shouldn't you be
typing like super fast don't worry he's
got this are you sure
all right look it's - oh it's been two
minutes okay hold on hey buddy how we
doing Coast Guard's gonna be on our
asses any second yeah I'll just just
tell the computer to load faster but
could you go with hacking Craig those
guards they're almost okay so stop the
guards with bullets can do I will but
there's a reasonable limit how about you
let me decide what a reasonable time
limit is for hacking into a high-level
security system all I'm asking for is an
ETA a minute what I knew you'd be one of
those people you think hacking is so
easy like I just hit some key strokes
and the clicky thing and then BOOM all
the time in the world
[Music]
pretty complicated slot a guessing game
to the security system lock the door and
buy us some time only right yeah wait
what no do it oh okay
so I'll just I'll hack into the head of
Security's gun and then the hacked gun
will shoot the guy right so you can't
get into the security system this isn't
hackers I'm not swordfish swordfish
wasn't even a character security systems
aren't like a place I can find by an
engine as fast as you can it's a little
hard with all this stress around me
stressful imagine you have all the time
in the world imagine I was wrong Craig
sucks okay Mike this will go down
together
[Music]
any questions so far
I like these videos because they're
always sort of you know like this is the
perception the masses get about how
these things work right and then then
you look at reality and there's not as
many hoodies and things like this and so
very different so you know that's just a
bit of fun to start off with but what I
really want to try and do today is to
look at a whole bunch of new key
security constructs and things that all
of us have available for free that are
really super easy to use but a lot of us
don't know are there and I thought what
I'd do is I'd sort of focus on on the
future so what are the things that we
can do not just in the future but now as
well and again things that like all your
users browsers have that work for free
and we're gonna talk particularly about
how to do things like turn all your
users browsers and the little beacons
that can send you information about
what's going on with your website when
stuff happens now that's kind of like
the future stuff and that's the cool
stuff and you're gonna see some pretty
neat things but one of the things that
always still strikes me is like how low
the bar is at the moment with security
and I wanted to try and pick an example
and I thought since on Kony other side
of the world I'll pick an Aussie example
and we'll just be a little bit
self-deprecating
for a while so this is a car of Bank the
largest bank in Australia they have tens
of billions of dollars of Revenue year
and they're in the news recently because
they had a data breach and I had to
report it we've actually finally got
mandatory disclosure laws in Australia
now and what actually happened is calm
bank was moving from one data center to
another one and as it turns out they had
to like decommission one data center and
they had to destroy a whole bunch of
data now the way they did this is they
put all this - were on a truck true
story data is on a truck and they're
driving the truck to the secure
destruction facility and we've got some
file footage of the truck just here
there's a truck for the cough data
and they've loaded it up they've got
like all the tapes all the disks are
gonna go to one those places you know
we've got the great big kind of
shredders for hard drives and things so
they put all the data on the truck
there's about 18 million records worth
of information you can see it's a lot of
data so they're driving it along and it
it turns out they might have put just a
little bit too much data on the truck
and they lost some of it seriously lost
some of it KPMG had to go and audit them
and they said they've retraced the route
of the truck to determine where they
could locate drives along the wrapper
unable to find any trace them they
literally look not metaphorically but
literally lost data of the back of a
truck biggest bank in the country so you
know I was saying like just how low the
bar is sometimes but this isn't exactly
like super sophisticated hacking it's we
had data fall off the back of truck now
when data does more metaphorically fall
off the back of a truck a lot of people
go and collect it and they send it to me
because I run this have a bent phone
service so I get people popping up all
the time saying I have found some data
and I thought you'd be interested in
having a look at it to have a REM tone
now that the challenge for me is that
I've got to make sure the data is legit
because there's a lot of stuff out there
that isn't it's fabricated and I also
want to do the right thing and I want to
make sure that the company that has lost
the data finds out about it so I want to
go through and do responsible disclosure
notification or sort of stuff and this
can be really really hard and I want to
show you a recent incidence of this - it
was really really hard and something
that we can all do that just makes it so
much easier for everyone and it has to
do with the data breach of this site
this is a dot fanfiction and you get a
little bit of a sense of the demographic
by the advertisement that's on there my
nine-year-old son wasn't in the audience
when I rehearse this so when one vampire
really loves another vampire
and you want to write a story about it
and this is what it is it's like a
rhotic app but for like elves and
warlocks and things like this yeah
that's okay
whatever fair enough so I verified it it
was legitimate so the data was actually
breached from this site and one of the
ways I verify there's some really simple
ways if you come across a bunch of data
and you like is it from this site I look
at the alleged data and I'll go and grab
say three random mela Nader addresses so
lots of people sign up at mela Nader
calm because they don't want to leave
their real email address now mail inator
addresses of public Mar boxes you can go
to Milan Aida to calm put in whatever
the aliases and see the contents of the
box so if I grab three of those
addresses and I go to like the password
reset feature and I drop them in and
then each one of those addresses gets a
mail chances are it's legit so I
verified this one this way and they'll
sent them an email hi I'm Troy hunt you
may remember me from such a data breach
now I don't do that but I give them a
message with enough information to
verify the authenticity so you'll see
here I've given them password hashes
next to email address or next to in this
case user names so you know you can go
to your database which you mean this is
them and they get this you go to the
database and go you know this one
daffodil 33 or whatever here's the md5
hash oh look at matches
maybe he's legit so I did that you sent
to two different email addresses two
different published email addresses on
the website I'm not guessing these
senator them on the 19th of July this
was last year and crickets like just
nothing and this is what often happens
you just get nothing back when people
try to let organizations know so I went
ahead and load of the data now this is
6th of August so in nearly three weeks
along later and have of impound dates of
birth email I don't know why you need
date the birth to read like vampire porn
I don't get the point anyway passwords
stored in both md5 and plaintext which
makes upgrading your hashing algorithm
really easy it's like here's the plain
text version
and as you can say that 79% of these
accounts had already been breached
before they were already in have I been
poned from previous incidents so that
has gone out there and inevitably people
start jumping onto their forum talking
about it now to me like the first thing
that should strike anyone reading this
on the forum is hey someone who uses our
forum
has just received an email saying that
their email address has been exposed in
a data breach of people who use the
forum the you know like you're trying to
join the dots together they go well this
is probably going to be a data breach so
someone else pops in azan said I got
this notice - all right so multiple
verification sounds legit now then it
sort of got really interesting so demon
goddess chimed in and demon go this was
a head evil tech wench Oh where's my
life the things I see so anyway she's
there and she says look it's not true
one would think that instead of scaring
users these companies would contact the
site itself oh okay but by how email so
she didn't quite feel it was legit and
she sent me an email said none of it
exists in my database
I've been working hellacious hours of my
day job demon goddess zero six one
I couldn't have these mental images like
what does demon goddess zero six one do
is make she's like a formal lawyer or
snow and he gets in a suit every day and
is a very normal person not on that
anyway she actually sent me two emails
sent me that one sent me another one
said now verified it doesn't exist in my
database didn't exactly clarify how
she'd verified it but apparently doesn't
exist I expect you to remove this from
your site now please
guess it's polite I I didn't I replied
and explained the situation but what I
found very interesting then was was
someone else came along and chimed in
and this was Bronx winds sure she's a
mighty dragon wench and she said this is
all true she said there's no gain in
hacking us we're not an e-commerce site
now I actually think this is really
interesting
there's loads and loads of organizations
out there or loads from websites
now if we can call these guys an
organization is probably just a
volunteer thing let's really say that
there's no perceived value in hacking us
because they can't imagine why someone
would want to do it there's a very easy
answer why someone would want to do it
because you're on the Internet look
that's the answer you're there if you're
looking at terrify people into buying
security software that was an extremely
effective gambit I am not actually have
any security software to sell so not
quite sure how that happened she went on
so private workshops and courses guilty
during these that we offer the
opportunity to purchase security
packages anyone who came to my workshop
the last couple of days how many things
did you buy from me nothing I gave you
stickers come on like that's what
happened if anyone's ever been posted
cause I'll check a stash them out there
later so you know it's it's not that and
I guess what I'm finding interesting
here is that there is often a I guess
almost a healthy degree of suspicion but
misplaced and eventually she said we
don't have high-priced lawyers who will
take them wait take he made a call you
lost the data you know as this working
out won't reporting with posting the
data said permission that's what I
intend to do was in August so far no
lawyers which is nice but you sort of
see like how difficult like all I wanted
to do with this site here is try and
disclose it privately so they could deal
with it in the right way and they could
let people know and they could try and
avoid this turning into an absolute [__]
storm of problems which it ultimately
did in the thread went on for ages and
the only reason I was able to get that
is from archives at all because they
went and deleted the whole thing because
it's not a good look for them obviously
eventually the penny dropped now another
example of this is this is Lewis this is
Dublin's rail system well this was Lewis
this is what the website used to look
like then earlier this year looked like
this this is the hole where like not a
lot of design aesthetic but this was the
whole website you are hacked I write
that you have
security holes you didn't reply next
time someone talks he press the reply
button now I don't know how this person
tried to contact them I don't know what
the tone of the email was like but
inevitably they were a little bit
surprised once this happened to their
website you know you would be now this
this bloke I think if we if we look at
their motives probably wasn't real good
give me a Bitcoin or I'll publish all
your data as best I can tell it's never
happened I certainly haven't had it sent
to me forever in phone but again it sort
of demonstrates the problem like how do
you get in touch with organizations and
let them know like what is the channel
this was their update after it happened
Louis website was compromised they
finished by saying this may take the day
to resolve gen 3 is Jan 10 this is the
website Jan 10 June 17 and if you look
at it today it looks like the previous
image so they're still down today and
what are we at now like four weeks on so
obviously this sort of absolutely
blindsided them now let's let's sort of
move on there and talk about solutions
because a really dead easy simple
solution to this and it's this has
anyone used a security Alec takes T's
file in their website one person
ants got help he knew his proposed down
which allows websites to define security
policies now here's what's super super
awesome about this all you do is you put
a text file there this is a text file
like of all the different things that
you could do security wise or spend
money on like this has got to be the
simplest thing ever you create a text
file and you put it on your site in the
well-known directory and I can show what
it looks like I'm have our been poned
looks just like that and what's awesome
about this is that if someone does
actually find a security vulnerability
or god forbid they find a data breach
and have a wimp and I'm not immune from
this then at least they're gonna know
how to find me and also how to
communicate securely as well just a text
file
so that's super cool this has been built
by a guy called ed Overflow he's to
certainly prepare the proposed spec
clever security researchers come up with
a really simple idea that just works
well now what's happening is we're
seeing it in all sorts of different
websites now implement this so here's
google's here's we contact encryption
acknowledgments policy would you like a
job there's a hiring section because the
sorts of people who find these
vulnerabilities you know maybe they're
looking for work and they've gone and
tried to do the responsible thing
Dropbox has got one similar sort of deal
you say we've got comments as well so in
this case Dropbox users hacker one so
they've got a bug bounty program via
hacker one BBC's got a big one with a
lot of comments and they're all the same
sort of thing that's just a plain text
file that adheres to a spec there's
actually a load of different websites
out there now using security up txt
files and you can see them all via Scott
Helms crawler dot ninja service so scott
has this little crawler that goes round
indexes the top 1 million websites every
single day and he puts a whole bunch of
stats on crawler ninja stats about
things like who's still serving pages
over HTTP and not HTTP who's using
modern security constructs and this list
here of who's actually using security
dot txt file and it's really fulfilling
to sort of see the numbers tick up for
something so simple and organizations
acknowledging that sometimes stuff goes
wrong so that's that simple user
security up txt file I'd love to see
your organization's appearing on Scott's
list and helping sort of bump that
number up so another thing that's been
happening a lot lately is we've seen
these guys features like they will know
who mage Kart is all right so this is
gonna be interesting mage Kart is sort
of like a collective of what appears to
be different groups who've been very
good at ripping off credit cards from
websites and I've been in the news our
heap particularly in the last year so
it's seen headlines like this British
Airways 380
thousand sets of payment details and
what's always been really impactful
about these stories is it's not just
like primary account number
it's the CVV as well so you know the
thing that you're never meant to have
after processing and people have been
seeing these headlines and going holy
[__] like British Airways is storing
CVVs and plane texts and people ripping
it off and it's not just British Airways
Ticketmaster had a really big one so
Ticketmaster same situation complete
credit card data not just that but any
other information entered into the page
as well just a couple of weeks ago oXXO
so oXXO creates a whole bunch of sort of
appliances and things for the kitchen
and what I want to do is is sort of show
you what's actually happening in these
cases and then show you a really good
defense against this so with the Aqsa
one what actually happened in fact what
happened with all of these is it was
just a very simple case of one line of
code being injected into the site so
here's what the code looks like it's
just a script tag in all of these cases
made cut whoever they are managed to get
this one script file embedded this was
the one in Ock so they called different
things in different other places they're
not always sort of the same indicators
of compromise but it's always a script
tag pulled from somewhere else now how
did I get it on these sites well a lot
of sites have things like content
management systems some of those content
management systems have vulnerabilities
a lot of those content management
systems are accessed by people with
terrible passwords that have appeared in
data breaches that spread all around and
then the passwords of reuse and people
go and test them now I'm into the CMS so
they get this script file on here this
is what the file on oxy looked like now
we're not going to read all of this but
if you have a look at like the first
half of it we see these arrays of field
names and what this script is actually
doing is it's listening to changes on
the field names so if there's a change
in this field get the value of the field
and send it off to somewhere else and I
want to mock this up just to sort of
show you how it works and then show you
how the defense works so what I did is I
created a version of
so locally now this is running on Oxford
comma I've got a host entry to certain
maps directly to my local oh yes now
this looks like a normal page normal
checkout page normal card data all the
sorts of stuff you'd expect to get when
you're paying for something but if I pop
open the dev tools and I jump over here
to the network tab and what we'll do is
just start filling in fields so let's
fill in this card number that'll do
and then as soon as I tab off there's a
request expiry expire a year CVV and
then each one of these changes is
sending off a request in this case to
evil cyber hacker bop calm incidentally
normally it's not like sending data to
mage Carter's hectic calm write a song
it's some like really really benign
looking name and you would have seen the
one with the J's file before it didn't
look suspicious but what it's doing is
it's making making a request oh this URL
we've got a token here which is
consistent across each one of those
requests so that we can tie them all
together we've got the host where the
request has come from which is up here
so you can imagine this being embedded
on multiple different sites near got the
host you knowit's come from and then
we've got the field name and then we've
got the value in the field and that's it
and like you see how simple this is this
is like literally a JavaScript key
logger if you can get that one-liner
script on a target site you can do stuff
like this now the thing is there's also
a really super super super easy defense
for this I mean other than just like not
leaving a CMS completely open but also
it's not always your own CMS - and
you'll see why in a moment so one of the
things we can do is we can use a content
security policy now I'm kind of curious
has anyone here built a CSP before now
if I take away all the people in my
workshop well over the last couple of
days it's gonna be like four or five
people because content security policies
are really really rarely used so Scott
stats from his crawler show it's like
three and a half percent of the top
million websites so I can't show you
what the content security policy does
and how it stops this sort of thing so
I've got another tab here it's exactly
the same site the
only difference is is that there's
narrow-ass ESP and I'll show you how the
CHP works if I reload this page and I'm
gonna look at the first request here and
I'm going to look at the response
headers I've got one down here that says
content - security - policy and this is
a really really simple CSP that says hey
you can load anything from self to Fox
or self you can load images and style
sheets and media and whatever else you
can also load scripts from self you can
have unsafe inline scripts trees like
blocks or scripts and then we've got
some definitions here around styles and
fonts there's a really really super
simple CSP but the main reason I wanted
to show this is that it fundamentally
changes the execution of this page and
we know that because if we go over to
the console tab we've got this this is
the JavaScript file that had been
embedded in the page again it wouldn't
normally be called evil cyber hacker
comma mage cartridge is but it's an
unexpected JavaScript file loaded from
an untrusted location so because my
content security policy doesn't say that
you can load scripts from evil cyber
hacker com if the script is loaded it
gets blocked so this is the browser
blocking it so the browser sees the CSP
sees was requesting guys no this wasn't
on the list now even if you managed to
compromise a CMS and get a script tag on
the page you're not going to be able to
modify headers you're not going to be
able to stop this defense from happening
so now the attacker has to go well I've
got to find another way like I've got to
actually find a way getting my script
onto one of the whitelisted script
sources which shouldn't be able to
happen if you choose wisely you know you
don't whitelist like all the github for
example so this is good like this will
stop the problem but there's something
else we can do because this doesn't
really let us know that there's a
problem so ask something like us as the
site administrators so we're going to
take this a little bit further I'll go
to another tab here and I'm going to
show you what my policy looks like this
time I've got the same console error
here but I'm just gonna reload the page
on the network tab because my policy has
changed very very slightly so here's my
policy
now I've got this report URI directive
and what this does is it says if this
content security policy fires if it
block something let me know and by
letting me know it's going to send a
JSON payload to the report URI that you
see there now there's a service that
Scott and I run report - Eri comm where
we enable organizations to send their
CSP reports there we process about half
a billion reports a day you can stand up
your own CSP endpoint as well try not to
do this yourself it's very easy so you
can set up your own one but I want to
show you what's actually in here so if I
go back to network tab just here I'm
going to close that one I'm gonna go
down all the way you'll see there's
actually an error here one of these
didn't load mage cottagey is blocked by
CSP so this is the browser doing its
thing with the CSP and this request just
here is to the report URI are defined
now if we give us a little bit more room
here you'll see that this is a row e
let's go down a little bit it's a post
request and it has a JSON body and
here's what's in that JSON body so it
gives me the blocked URI so what was
attempted to be loaded from another
location so imagine you're like
responsible for a website and you're
getting this report you can go that's a
bit weird you know like I can't remember
embedding mage Carter J us from evil
cyber hacker comm I wonder where it
happened well I've got the document URI
the document URI tells me the URI that
triggered this particular CSP violation
and this is what I meant earlier on when
I said like turning all your users into
little beacons because anyone around the
world using your website and getting hit
with this script is going to be sending
your report letting you know so this is
really super powerful you can take this
and you can go and figure out how on
earth they're getting script on your
site which isn't meant to be there so
try and use a CSP the CSP is a
super-awesome you can always create a
CSP and not block you can create a CSP
that only reports like you feel worried
about breaking stuff you create the same
policy except it's just content -
security - policy
report - only and then I won't break
stuff and just to give you an idea of
how innocent you can be in the whole
thing the Ticketmaster incident wasn't a
vulnerability in their service
it's a vulnerability in this service
this is inventor and an inventor does
chatbots
now because Ticketmaster decided to put
a chatbot on their pages a lot of
companies do these days and because
inventor then got compromised you get
like this cascading supply chain of
vulnerabilities you know you're
dependent on inventor and venture then
gets injected with the script that comes
from somewhere else it cascades all the
way up and runs in the browser so you
can be perfectly innocent in the whole
thing but if a third party that you're
using has a compromised then it's game
over so they also see us pay side of
things one of the one of the other areas
that I think is getting really
interesting at the moment and I want to
sort of talk about where things
typically go wrong with a good example
is around IOT now as far as Internet
connected things go a car is pretty
significantly there's a mess and leaf
and a few years ago I was running a
workshop in Norway and we do this
exercise on the first day where what you
do is you take your mobile device like
this and you route it through your PC
and then you run Fiddler on the PC who's
won Fiddler before they were in full of
developers almost everyone so you're
unfit ler so fiddler you can configure
to allow remote computers which includes
devices you can configure to allow
remote computers to connect and they
proxy through there so it's just a
couple of steps you're now sending
everything from your device through your
fiddler
so the bloke was in my class he he said
look it's interesting my car has a
companion app that looks like this and I
was kind of curious I was like why like
do you really want to connect your car
what's the value proposition of this and
he said well the reason we do this in
Norway is it's so cold we've got to be
able to turn the heater on in the car
before we get in now some of you are
nodding I think this happens in the UK
sometimes as well right so it's very
different in Australia Australia
gets so hot if you get in your car too
quickly and you sit on the seat belt
this happens and this is real is in the
news is a couple of weeks ago I was like
45 degrees or something guy gets in his
car not so good
anyway this is not about like branded
tattoos seat belts so different set of
problems in Norway now he was curious
right like how does my phone know how to
talk to my car because there's a lot of
nice and lease out there a lot of mobile
apps and what he was really asking is
he's like what is the API key is there
some sort of a bearer token for example
and he's trying to sort of decompose the
requests figure out what the API key is
and he discovers that the API key so the
secret that you need to connect to the
car is printed in the windscreen of
every car because the API key was the
VIN number so I was walking around
Norway just like taking photos and this
and less that's my life that's my
leisure because now you own anything
that you could do it the mobile app so
the mobile app could turn on the heating
or also turn on the air-conditioning
pull back the trip history pull back the
battery status and you're gonna see what
these requests look like in the moment i
obfuscated the last few digits because
you could do some pretty nasty stuff but
also the last few digits are innumerable
so you could take one VIN number and
then just keep guessing other VIN
numbers and all these other cars would
start to pop up and we had to verify
this because we're like this this is
actually a genuinely serious problem
we're gonna need to do something about
this so we verified it we waited until
we could identify one other car pull
back something B'nai and we didn't start
changing climate control or anything you
know pull back the battery status for
example and then I got in touch with
Nissen and I sent a tweet it's like hey
does anyone have a security contact at
Nissen that that's it's a bit like
shining the bat light because
immediately runs like oh crap behind
isn't that a problem
and I got someone from this and pretty
quickly to their credit and we we had a
an email exchange had a phone call a lot
of backwards and forwards and they took
it very seriously for about a week and
then I got busy you know though they had
other stuff to do and I couldn't get a
reply from that I like I couldn't drive
them to the point where they're actually
going to fix the problem by though just
I think they just put in the too hard
basket and I was being annoying and it's
you know that's a hard thing because
what do you do like you know that
there's a serious vulnerability like
this is not just a major privacy issue
pulling back data on someone else's car
but I don't want randos changing things
in my car from the other side of the
world that just feels maybe it's just me
it feels weird so it's kind of trying to
figure out what to do and about a month
after I first discovered it I was having
a bit of a google around and I found
that other people had discovered it too
and what actually happened is other
people had said the Nissen app is so
crap that we have got a better way of
turning on the heater whilst you're
laying in bed or snuggly what you do is
you go to this URL with the VIN number
and you just change the VIN number to
your own and then you spot that as a
favorite in your browser make car hot
make car cold and these people were very
proud of themselves because they're like
we have solved the problem now it's easy
I think some people probably upset
because they're going where the hell am
I
you a changing state with the get
request this is no good but there's what
a bit like just get request VIN number
in the URL and I'm looking at going do
you not realize what you have found like
you could change it for anyone so I got
to the point okay well we got to go
publish this we got to make this public
because that's the only way change is
going to happen like you do get to this
point where it's like they're just not
paying attention gonna get public and I
discovered that Scott helm had an s and
leaf which made things much easier so
now I've got someone who's in the same
field knows what they're doing let's do
a blog post together and I want to do
something which was like impactful
enough to drive change but didn't overly
sensationalize it
so what we decided to do is a video and
I went back to Australian i sat by my
pool Scots in England which is way looks
kind of sad and and I did this video
show you like this very very short clip
of it here controlled from this end I
guess the first thing is I consider your
you'll be jet run it's cold there should
we look here to have well we might be
able to do is the heater super can bring
up to Australia temps for a little bit
so here's what we did next I hit this
URL now he has since sold the car
Fitzy's VIN number doesn't have it
anymore so here's the RL just to get
request you can see the VIN number in
there and of course if you modify that
VIN number to another one it's game over
the last five digits of that then were
the ones that are innumerable and then
it would respond then here's the JSON
response that came back and you see it
also has his user ID so there's a little
bit of personal information leakage just
in the request so you know if you sort
of put the Hat on of what could I do
with this well if I could just keep in
numerating numbers not only could I find
the user ID and this one does kind of
identify right so I hit this and here's
what happened next and that was like now
he's he doesn't and that was pretty
impactful and then we got all these big
news headlines as like car hacking and
it's like always lament that a little
because it's like no someone else can't
drive your car but yeah it was kind of
look if it drives change and it makes
the right stuff happen that's good and
and you wouldn't believe it suddenly it
was important to listen like it wasn't
important when it was just me it's
different when it's like wide magazine
in New York Times like stuff tends to
happen then but
what are the sort of points I wanted to
make here I think it's a really
interesting lesson for people building
api's about how this sort of stuff
happens because we see it time and time
again so I mean let's imagine sort of
the workflow this we imagine we've got
our our Nissan Leaf user here very happy
little nests and leaf user saving the
world it's an electric vehicle and they
use the app and they're communicating
with the mobile app their entire
experience with the api's and everything
else is via an app the testers entire
experience is via the app but the app is
then communicating in the backend to the
API you don't see the API you don't see
a URL in the address bar or anything
like this it's hidden behind the veneer
of a rich client app now just to be
clear as well it's not like the Nissen
leaf was running Apache right it doesn't
actually run the web server it them back
channels to the car so it goes out of a
GSM or something like that so we get
very very focused on this part of the
communication we get very very focused
on how do people interact with our app
and we very often overlook this part and
what I find is there's a lot of
assumption that's made so developers
assume that people will always use the
app and then the app can only
communicate to the API this way because
hey I built the app and the API they'll
always work together no one's going to
go directly to the API and change it but
it's an assumption and we now let's say
about assumptions and that keeps leading
is back to the same position again and
again and again so assume that people
are going to use your API in ways that
you never expected because they will
they'll discover what the api's are
behind you rich client apps and they'll
make them do things that you never
expected now there was a follow-up to
the nests and leaf story and it all
started when they actually headed off
live like 6 weeks it was Aegis they took
a long time to fix it they got it back
online and then then Scott sent me a
screen cap and he said have a look at
the app do you see anything unusual
about the app and I'm looking at this
image it's a normal app and then I'm
reading
the app and this is literally what
Nissen put in their app to control cars
and we were curious where did this come
from
we found it there's this stackoverflow
question and if we scroll down there's
an answer says this so someone had gone
to stack overflow and literally copied
and pasted this to control a car and
they never understood what a dip and you
know what's even worse
what's the second highlighted word
spirit right what's the second word they
they hadn't even copied and pasted it
like they'd literally like they're
reading it and retyping it no idea what
it does and one of the reasons why I
show this is to sort of demonstrate that
even really large well-resourced
organizations can still just make the
most egregious cock-ups with stuff like
this and just because you're going and
buying like a car doesn't mean it's
going to be any better than any of the
other ayats he connected crap you can
get these days there's one other thing
actually it happened now because it was
off so long offline so long a whole
bunch of people got upset because now
they had to get out of bed to turn the
car on and one bloke from the UK left
this feedback on the Google Play Store
and he wasn't very happy and in he's
very polite British Way took a shot at
me and I was actually kind of chuffed I
was like hey listen this is good like
this is a reminder that people out there
literally need saving from themselves so
I printed out and framed and put on my
desk
and you know again like the thing that
just continues to strike me is like how
massive an organization Nissen was and
how bad this was in the copying but
there's one of those multifaceted
vulnerabilities so speaking of
vulnerabilities one of the things that
we still have happening a lot is
cross-site scripting like cross-site
scripting is still a big thing we're
getting a bit better at it not
necessarily because we as builders are
getting better but because frameworks
are getting better go and use asp.net
MVC everything gets outputting coded
doesn't always save you but it does move
us in the right direction but we still
got a lot of XSS and I've got this
little video here that I saw a Dutch
journalist do a couple of years ago a
guy cut brento de vente and he went and
tested a whole bunch of Dutch banks
because he wanted to try and find XSS
vulnerabilities in banks and I'll play
this udderly is very short but
everything that you see in here in the
video is done with JavaScript and it's
injected by cross-site scripting
[Music]
which is a good fun right now
incidentally when hackers find
vulnerabilities like cross-site
scripting with banks they normally don't
do that right like they do think about
this way they do anything that you can
do with JavaScript so like in your minds
go or what can do with JavaScript yeah
basically anything right so you can do
almost anything with JavaScript in fact
if you look at the URL right towards the
end of it you can see he's got an evil
statement in there so eval is obviously
like concatenated up a string somewhere
possibly to bypass XSS filters and then
he's just availing the string and it
executes so obviously we've got a lot of
XSS out there we've got some really
really cool defenses that are either
natively built into the browser but a
lot of people don't know they're there
or how they work or they turn them off
we'll talk about in a moment and there's
some other really neat stuff we can do
to show you how this works I created a
little app called search for beer it
does one thing beer that's it says you
search for beer now you'll see up in the
address bar we've got beer it's up here
it's parsed in a query string it's then
reflected down here so this is reflected
insofar as we provide information with
the request it could be in the career
string could be in a header could be in
a buddy and then it's reflected back in
the response now if I was to go and make
this a bit more interesting and actually
put some script in here so we'll do a
script alert I like there like that Bam
Bam Bam and we'll close off that script
tag like so yeah yeah I know I just
can't say I need beer use it a few times
let's go search BAM okay so this is like
super super simple stuff and you can
picture in your mind's what's probably
happened but just for the sake of
transparency down in the source code
here we go
now that the interesting thing here is
you think about it from the browser's
perspective the browser's just like hey
I got an HTML response it had a script
tag in I'm just going to execute what's
in the script so in a way this is kind
of doing like exactly what you would
expect it to do but in another way your
browser actually has defenses to stop
this from happening
first place and in fact the only way I
could do this in chrome is I had to turn
the defense off so if I go back to the
network tools and I reload this page
like so and I go to the first request
here and I go to the response you still
like the area good in the response
headers I have a header which is X XSS
protection and I'll set that to zero
your browser has a native XSS auditor
and what the auditor does is it looks
for script that appears on the page but
has come with the request because that
smells like XSS right and the browser
goes not we're not gonna let any of that
happen we're going to stop that script
from running and in fact if we look at
the source code of a page what you'll
see as it's gone and highlights of that
script and said hey this has been flags
so if we go down to here actually no
we're gonna steal the next one I'm sorry
see it on the next one so at the moment
we've done just turned it off the next
one which is where else it's going with
this let's try it here Bam Bam no script
that's what I was just looking for down
here token contains a reflected XSS
vector so it's identified that this has
come in the script and it's disabled it
now what we're seeing here is the
difference between turning the auditor
off together and in this case the
auditor running in what's referred to as
mode 1 so if I reload this page so I can
see the response header you go back to
the first request which is there and get
into here mode 1 so mode 1 will actually
stop it from running now this looks good
but you got to sort of think it through
a little bit further as well if someone
is able to make a request to the page
with a piece of script that then also
appears somewhere in the response the
script doesn't run so what if someone
disabled a piece of script deliberately
it's not that they wanted XSS they
actually wanted to disable a piece of
script maybe some script in there to
block nasty stuff an attacker says I'm
going to stop the script from running
and the only well the way I can do that
very very easily is I can just include
that script somewhere in a career string
parameter so this is a bit of a problem
be
now what we've done is we've just killed
a part of the site which was meant to
work which brings us to the next one
here now before I do the search let's
have a look at the header so here that
header now we have mode block so
exercise protection is on the motor set
the block this is actually the browser
default if you don't change XSS headers
at all your browser will do this by
default now around about here you might
be wondering why would you turn it off
well because it broke something on a
legacy app and hey as an easy fix
because sometimes people do pass around
clumps of JavaScript in query strings
because that's the way the app was
designed like there are it is hard to
fathom how many problems there are like
if you start doing that that people turn
it off because of that reason so let's
have a look at what happens now because
now we're on on and block and we'll go
there we'll go here we'll drop that
script in we'll search let's see what's
going to happen this time well it's
actually a local connection okay so well
there we go
hmm maybe it's too small at my local IAS
going slow error blocked breaks is this
order so by default what will happen if
the excersice order two fires will kill
the whole page it's like weird it's not
gonna load it at all something very
suspicious has happen we need to kill
everything so this is really cool this
stops that problem before which is that
an attacker can come and start disabling
pieces of script so that moves us in the
right direction but per the CSP
discussion earlier on as well I would
actually like to know right like if I've
got XSS on my site and even though the
auditor is blocking it I still want to
know that I got a cross-site scripting
on my site so there's one more thing we
can do as well no I'm actually gonna
connect back to this Wi-Fi because I
think this is also well is the industry
London connection did let's try and
connect again so I'm because of
experience I'm not actually going to be
dependent on external things might just
try speakers here allow some there we'll
disconnect that one
going to here but it is possibly loading
external assets as well which is what's
going a little bit slow so anyway well
that's connecting maybe we'll go here
and we'll try one more thing here's what
it is dev tools Network tab open we're
gonna reload this page back up to here
down to here one mode block but then
I've got this report attribute and I've
got an endpoint here where if there is a
violation it's going to send a report
too and this is a little bit like the
CSP reporting before and it goes back to
the earlier point if you can turn all of
your visitors browsers and a little
beacons that let you know when something
goes wrong so in order to demonstrate
this one I need to open up fiddler and
actually catch that request on the wire
we're not going to be able to see it in
Chrome's dev tools so we're going to go
to here try the attack again BAM like
that search for beer that's going to
make the request in Fiddler here we've
now got a request to this path which is
the one that was more my report value
into the inspectors and then if I go and
have a look at the JSON request this is
what you get and you can see that the
request URL has the full URL that was
requested including the payload and if
you ever get one of these reports you
know that someone has managed to get
that script tag running on a browser
somewhere which is cool so again we're
like just orchestrating everyone's
browser and there are these little
beacons reporting stuff back to you what
I love about this and the CSP stuff and
the security texty stuff as well so all
of this is like totally for free you get
this without paying any money whatsoever
you just have to turn the things on
there's a lot of security out there that
would like to charge you a lot of money
very often for things that don't
actually do what they're meant to do
which brings me to this so I have done a
lot of talks before around extended
validation certificates and basically
how pointless they are and I want to
sort of make a point here because this
is a few things have changed since I did
the talk in London last year and delved
into it
now one thing that's changed as comodo
is no longer comodo well actually
they're no longer come out of Okamoto CA
and now they're no Lucca moto CA now
they're sick tiga they still sell
extended validation ssl certificates so
you know how most websites you go
through over https is a padlock and
that's it just a padlock its domain
validation you've proven that you can
control the domain if you go to say your
bank you might see extended validation
the bank's name up there in the address
bar they've had to prove that they are
the bank in order to get that displaying
and commercial certificate authorities
have been pimping these really hard
because you basically can't sell domain
validation certificates anymore because
let's encrypt has come along and done it
for free and frankly done it better
because they've made it automated as
well so see ace lav on the premise of
things like the green address bar
criminally displaying your company name
incidentally what colour is it in chrome
today gray
exactly it's not green anymore you've
got to change all the marketing here's a
fun fact or the fun trivia fact who
knows what colour it is in Safari on iOS
it's green but then DV is gray so you've
got to remember which browser displays
at which way and it's changing you used
to be green in chrome I can barely keep
up how's everyone else going to keep up
so lets you know that your site is
secure and they gotta say this
immediately gives them the confidence to
complete their transaction and and this
is the sales pitch right like if you
show the green bar which isn't green we
have serviced this now if you show the
green bar then people will go through
and they'll actually check out and they
will pay for the item in their shopping
cart and again like we normally see this
used by the likes of financial
institutions and we see it used by
entities like PayPal now just realize
I'm going to need an internet connection
so this is going to be interesting let's
try this who thinks that PayPal has an
extended validation certificate
Jesus not many a couple who things are
doesn't doesn't really add up but I get
the cinnamon merit so a bunch of people
think it does now the fun thing here is
that if we go to paypal.com and there is
not an extended validation certificate
will you leave and not use the site
because this is all it is right it is a
visual control and it's entirely
predicated on users changing their
behavior in the absence of that
indicator we seem to have internet let's
say it goes slow internet builds
suspense it's coming come on
okay so as you can see no AV indicator
although the connection dropped again
okay now as you can see now even it's
just really really super slow no Evie
indicator is that interesting
what happens if using Firefox let's try
that that might make it interesting it
might be fiddly killing good point let's
get rid of fiddler
once you've route everything through
they're fun things do tend to happen
let's see here we go here oh can I just
so that everyone sees is I can do ah
if you think it's fiddler he's like damn
Troy coming on doing his tricks to try
and trick us into thinking there's no
Evie on PayPal I'll show him oh look at
still TV well it looks like TV doesn't
it this is the same certificate that
served up the both here's the fun story
with this I was doing a talking in DC in
Sydney in September and as part of that
talk I show a website using Evie and a
website using DV and the one that I
always used to demonstrate Evie was
PayPal and then I'm up on the stage and
I'm like an auto part here's PayPal as
you can see it's got Evie oh [__] what's
happened it's gone and I was literally
was on the stage of god this is amazing
there's no more Evie and I got off and
Scott was there as well and we sat down
and I pull this thing apart we're trying
to figure out what's happening and we're
like oh this is gonna be amazing like
they're gonna fix it really really soon
because otherwise people abandon their
shopping carts and they won't buy
anything because
comodo told us
they'll September and we're still here
and what's ultimately happened is the
way that they have implemented that
certificate in the window certificate
store it's no longer showing the visual
indicator for TV but Firefox is good as
a certificate store it shows things
differently so in Firefox you get the
indicator in anything on windows
including edge you don't get the
Vindicator and what I find fascinating
is like four months later they haven't
changed it now I propose that PayPal has
the money to go out buy another AV
certificate if it's important doesn't
seem to be important I would love really
really like to find someone at PayPal
and go hey by any chance if you're like
a big test of this like are you having
people abandon ship well they wouldn't
because otherwise they'd get a bloody
stevia so you know obviously it's not
doing anything for like one of the
world's largest online payment
processors however let's not let that
stop people promoting buying Eevee
certificates and I want to give you a
couple of fun examples here so there's
this little video here that Komodo
now Komodo CEO now sexy go has been
promoting in order to go and buy
certificates I'm going to show you what
this video looks like and it
demonstrates the importance of a website
having an Eevee certificate to a site
with an Eevee SSL certificate see their
browser address bar turned green
whenever they are in a secure or HTTPS
page typically among the most critical
during a session right at the moment of
truth when they're weighing whether or
not to go forward with a transaction the
striking visual indicator accompanied by
information certifying their business
name location and the certification
Authority that validated it as presented
providing needed
reassurance to continue right at the
moment of truth that's that sounds much
dirtier when I say all of that and the
green address bar which we would have
the discussion it's not green except for
the times that it is you say the website
there's this website called Excalibur
cutlery Excalibur cutleries got Evie so
now more people will trust their website
except the problem is is that when you
look at Excalibur cutlery and you know
actually now it's really interesting
let's actually look at their certificate
certificate oh that's embarrassing
now they're still promoting the video so
I think it just sort of says something
about how sophisticated they actually
think people are that are buying even
these certificates there's another
funnel in fact last year that on Twitter
awhile ago and then someone emailed me
this one and they said are you like this
oh I just got an email to renew my a-v
certificate and incidentally you're
paying at least hundreds of dollars
every couple of years not much money for
a big company but it's hundreds of
dollars that you don't need to pay as
well and this guy forwarded me this
email and said you know there's this bit
here in the bottom right boost online
sales with Evy SSL and there's a there's
a testimonial from this guy Chris and
Chris is saying this product really
creates consumer confidence my sales
increased 20% at mostly dead calm and
about now I think he cans all see where
this is going
damn
and every single example I check
everyone's like ditching a VA
certificates enrolling over to DV which
makes me normally happy and as it's not
to be perfectly clear it's not a hate
thing about TV
I don't hate Eevee I hate the
misrepresentation of something doing
something that just fundamentally cannot
do and I think this sort of really sums
it up security controls that rely on the
absence of positive visual indicators
don't work people are terrible at
looking at things like URLs or anything
in the address bar and making decisions
about the security posture of it so what
it's doing is it's creating a veneer of
security which in actual fact doesn't
work and I wanted to sort of try and
find a good illustration to wrap the
talk up that that is I guess like an in
real life analogy of that and I found
this which is a biometric padlock now it
turns out the padlock does have a screw
on it and the screw does what you would
probably think it does and that's not
the fun bit though the fun bit is the
guy found is this bloke called the lock
picking lawyer and all he does is he
goes around and pulls all physical
padlocks so he finds this problem and he
reports it to the maker of the padlock
and they had the most epic response they
said this lock is invincible to people
who do not have a screwdriver and this
is basically what evey is thank you very
much
hey I know the guy on boat cruises and
stuff we got like two minutes does
anyone have any questions everyone wants
to go on the boat cruise and drink beer
all right so hey if you have any
questions ask me on the boat if you tell
me alone thanks guys
[Applause]
[Music]